I think that's my 28,000th plant.
And I think I'm close to my goal.
The parents, smooth yellow, wrinkled green, and the offspring.
Yes, no mistaking it, the wrinkled green ones are recessive,
the smooth yellow dominant.
I've observed for 20 years to learn that.
Today, children, I feel like telling you about a man who,
you could say he had a passion for peas.
Me too, I like him.
Well, good, I'm glad.
But I'm telling you about the father of genetics.
I want you to solve a riddle.
Listen carefully, no?
There are six billion of them.
They're all other than the same, ah, but yet they're all different.
Reeds of sand.
Dan and bee, peas in a pod.
The leaves on the trees.
It's all of us.
Humans, yes.
That's quite a lot, six billion.
One, two, three, four.
Can you imagine how long it would take just to count up to six billion?
Would be a long time. Too long.
Two hundred years.
How come they're all different and yet all the same?
we're all like one another because we're all human and different because no two are identical
these are men to women there are boys and girls some big some small blondes redheads blacks whites
yellows there's the strong and the sly say maestro how does it happen that we're so different and
why are there so many different animals yeah that's one of nature's greatest secrets and we
still don't comprehend it. Do you remember Darwin? Yes, your evolution. He had a long beard like, um,
yes, like mine. He showed that we all descended from some sort of ape. And then we all evolved,
evolved a lot. Have you evolved? Evolved, I'm evolved. Darwin showed that all living species
change over time. Yes, but how do they change? By adaptation. As I recall, Darwin observed that
The little finches that ate leaves had thin beaks to cut them up, and the ones that ate nuts had large beaks to break them.
Yes, the little finches are born different. Why is that?
On account of the eggs.
Exactly.
Through the egg, the parent finches transmit their genes to their chicks.
That's pretty complicated, all that. And what's a gene?
I wouldn't have one.
Me neither. The only genes I got are blue.
Shut up.
You both have them. Birds, all animals, every living creature has genes.
And who discovered that?
A man who was a quiet genius and was interested in simple peas.
It all happened in Moravia, in the heart of Europe, some time ago.
You see, Gregor, you can graft this good branch on this apple tree.
How'd you do it?
I want to watch.
How is it possible for the same tree to give a different fruit?
That, my son, is a mystery of nature.
You come and help me now, son.
Yes, sir.
You owe three days of work per week.
Come with me.
Yes, sir. As soon as we finish...
Right now! I'm not waiting. I need you.
Yes, sir, it's the best I've raised so far.
Six months.
But that ram, sir, it's the result of many years of selective breeding.
I can't give him to you.
Did to have a ram so perfect.
You have to select the best parents.
Look, look, this used wool is excellent.
That ram's horns are straight.
They pass things on to the young ones in that way, little by little.
Yes, but how?
Ah, well, there, my lad, I really can't say.
Flour is fertilized by the pollen.
Put there, it produces a seed.
But how is it that the pistil and the pollen produce the seed, which then results in a flower, and not something else?
That, my boy, uh, we aren't sure about.
The lad is intelligent. He should go on with his studies, but we have so little money.
Good man, take a look. Got a hole in his sock.
He's so poor he can't buy two pairs of stockings, eh?
A bumpkin. What's he doing here?
He's an idiot.
And you? Who, me?
Me?
Yes, you. I doubt that your fine socks make you intelligent.
Tell me what is required for a flower-bearing plant to produce a seed.
Uh, you have to shake it.
In autumn, in autumn, in autumn, in autumn, autumn.
In autumn. I have to shake it in autumn.
You are ignorant. Now sit down.
What do you say, Mendel?
It requires that pollen penetrate into the pistol, Professor.
Pollen come from?
From the same plant or another one.
If it comes from a different variety, it will produce a hybrid.
Very good, Mendel.
As for you two, with your perfect silk stockings and all, Mendel could teach you a thing or two.
That will be all for today.
So Mendel could teach us that.
Why don't we teach him to listen, huh?
See that?
He's scared. Look at him.
You see, he doesn't even dare look at us.
It's my turn, my turn.
To hit him with a stone?
Go on, sneak back to your farm.
The geese are calling you.
Pigs are, too.
Look at how he's dressed. His coat's too tight.
Bumpkin.
All worn out?
It's true I have a hole in my sock.
My jacket is too small and worn.
You, you have fine clothes.
But all the same, I can teach you a little lesson.
Custom made my jacket.
It's brand new, Scottish wool.
Well, your fine clothes are going to look like mine.
Jacket's ruined.
My socks are full of holes.
My shirt, just look at my shirt.
And if you start in again, you'll get another little lesson.
I'd like a piece of bread and three carrots.
Two carrots.
Come into my office, young man.
Here.
Eat this and listen to me.
Go on, go on, you must eat.
I know that you have no money.
And if you go on this way, Mendel, you're going to be sick.
But you deserve to go on with your studies, so here's what I suggest.
Go see the brothers at the Augustan Monastery.
Thank you, Professor.
This is the refectory where we take all our meals.
Here you'll be fed, don't worry.
Here's Brother Matthias, our botanist.
He takes care of our garden.
Come, I'll show you.
I'm sure that you will be very interested.
Tell me, are you passionately interested in botany, my son?
Oh, yes, Father. I'm a peasant, son of a peasant, and I've studied the natural sciences.
Splendid. At last I will have someone I can tell about my plants. Come and see.
I have many varieties of beans and peas. Come along. You know, peas are very interesting.
This is our common prayer chapel.
Generally, in nature, when plants and animals reproduce, they give birth to offspring who look like them.
But exceptions exist.
Why the exceptions?
Imagine these peas. These peas you see here, they're going to reproduce.
The rest?
I resemble you quite a lot.
Does it resemble me?
It's the spitting image of my dear mother.
Yes, you're right.
For humans, it's the same.
Why do children inherit the characteristics of their father or mother, or sometimes both?
Any ideas?
It's a mystery.
Why is it the peas are all yellow ones, and then for no reason, green ones suddenly reappear?
I've noticed other things that I can't explain.
I think we should carry out an experiment only.
It might take a long time.
A very long time.
Lunchtime.
We're being called to the refectory.
For which we give thanks, O Lord, amen.
A splendid sauerkraut. What a good idea. Potatoes and carrots.
Ah, the wonderful vegetables of Father Matthias.
There's nothing like it.
What are you planting there?
Peas, Father.
And there?
Peas, Father. And there too, Peas, Father.
Yeah, you're planting a great many peas, my son.
I'll need thousands of them for my experiment, Father.
Look, here all of the pea pods are green.
There, they're all yellow.
Here, the flowers are white.
There, the flowers are mauve.
Here, the plants short, they're long.
Oh, what energy, my son.
There's gonna be thousands.
What's the purpose, huh?
Well, I'll crossbreed them, Father,
and make hybrids and observe the results
over several generations.
And it's pea soup with little peas,
and little peas and a tiny slice of salted pork.
Let us thank the Lord for our daily bread,
as well as the tiny little peas that Brother Gregor grew.
Amen.
Yeah, daily bread, daily peas is all we get now.
You know what now, my son?
I go on cross-breeding peas.
I'll put the pollen of the pink flowers into the green pods and the white flowers into the yellow pods and the long into the short.
Anyway, not so fast.
What a lot of work.
Of course, I understand.
The fact is, my eyes aren't up to it.
Just a bit too weak.
But mine aren't much better, Father.
You see, I wear glasses.
Now I take pollen of the pink flower and put it on the pistol of the white flower.
Mom, Father, we're being called for a meal.
No, my son, leave me here. I'd like to watch the sun set one last time.
No, father. You're going to catch cold.
Don't worry about me. I have lived a very long time.
Remember, I will always be with you.
I know the work that you are doing is important.
Now, my son.
Very well, father.
Give me your blessing.
Thank you, my son. I don't want to be alone.
Father, my...
Yes.
It's a few potatoes, eh?
You plant them.
Very busy.
Start by some of your...
But Dana's not here, my brother.
You can see that we've planted peas.
But no more peas. We can do without peas. We don't want any more.
We hate them. We're gonna rip up your garden.
No, no. A great experiment is underway. It will revolutionize science.
Yeah, well, right now, there is a revolution in my stomach.
You can plant them. There's a good place to plant potatoes over there in the field.
Plenty of room.
But this is the cloister garden.
It's occupied, but you'll plant your potatoes on the other side of the wall, huh?
I'd like some help to get over the wall.
No.
Good.
Pain is right here.
Yeah, where's my foot?
That's it, I found it. Now I'm certain I'm right.
Brother, what did you find exactly?
The characteristics of plants are passed on by pairs of little particles,
two for color, two for shape, two for size.
Certain particles are dominant.
Look here, no question, yellow is dominant.
It's a dominant characteristic.
I'm not too sure I really understood what it meant.
It's pretty complicated.
Remember Darwin, children, in The Origin of Species, he said...
The laws of heredity are still largely unknown to us.
Back to our story. Some years later, Mendel would discover those laws of heredity.
What he discovered was the gene. The gene, the very basis of modern genetics.
I should explain a bit.
The pea has two genes for determining its color. One for yellow, one for green.
But the yellow one is dominant. If it's together with a green gene, yellow wins.
And the peas will have a yellow pod. But then, the next generation, what happens then?
You see, once again, it's the dominant yellow gene that wins over the green in here.
But here, what do we find?
Two genes are green.
And so the color green, which wasn't in the second generation,
reappears in the third generation.
So thanks to reproduction, which mixes up the genes of previous generations,
nature creates marvelous varieties.
It explains how children can inherit features of their parents and their grandparents.
Then their aunts and their uncles, and so on and so forth.
20 years of research, I'm able now to present the results of my work
to the scientific society, and I will.
The transmission of hereditary features is achieved in the following manner.
The corpuscles group together according to a process which I define mathematically as being in the order of the...
These gentlemen are the results of my work.
One of them understood. I've got to find another way.
True. Nobody had any idea about the importance of his work.
Mendel was too far ahead of his time.
If we can select and modify plants, we ought to be able to do it with animals.
With a cow?
No, it would take too long. I'll try with bees.
They multiply very quickly. I'll have more generations.
What's that for?
It's to chase bees away.
They don't like the smoke.
Can I see it?
Me neither. I don't like smoke.
What do we do now?
We'll breed a new variety of bee that will produce much honey.
Now we begin.
Move the queen bee, and I place her in this new hive with a bit of honey.
I take a few males from the swarm and place them with the queen.
Of course, this work is going to take many years.
This does.
These bees here, they produce twice as much honey as the others.
i know that i'm on the right it's pork with honey apparently it's a chinese delicacy
peas around i suppose no my brother no more peas around yes honey cake my brother yuck
and this my brother is honey something we want a location yeah we're planting just a few peas
there's not much room around here plenty of room in the field right here i wouldn't recommend it
Well, this garden is intended for all the monks, I believe, yes?
Uh-huh.
On the swarming of his bees, he calculated the energy used in their flight.
He'll perform thousands of experiments with trees to improve varieties of fruit.
Experiments in meteorology.
But his greatest work would always be peas and genes.
Genes are at the very heart of modern biology.
But we have to wait for many years to see recognition of Mendel's work,
so long hidden, disputed, until the world saw its great importance.
This theory here is entirely based on pure chance, and yet he makes it into a law.
It's no sense.
Monsieur DeVries.
Gentlemen, this so-called Mendel's law, it also applies to a whole range of plants.
And to a whole range of animals as well.
Well, then, why not apply it to humans too? Mendel has truly discovered genes.
You see, it's genes that make us what we are.
For instance, a fly or an elephant or a boy or a girl, and Mendel's discoveries opened the way for many, many more.
Mr. Muller, would you be good enough to catch that fly, if you please?
Certainly, Mr. Morgan.
Genes are located in these little sticks.
Chromosomes.
Have you found, Mr. Avery?
That genes are made of DNA, a sort of long molecule.
DNA is life.
Watson, quick!
What are you doing?
We're modeling a molecule of DNA?
What can you see, Mrs. McClintock?
My star jumping genes.
This is gibberish, Mr. Ocha.
It's the genetic code.
I have just decoded it.
Now we've learned that DNA is contained in genes which transmit characteristics.
And that genes play a part in producing all the substances that the body needs.
And scientists can change genes in the laboratory.
It's called genetic engineering.
Thanks to this genetic engineering, we are producing new medicines and curing hereditary diseases before they start.
For the very first time, man is trying to guide his own evolution.
He's starting to program his own future?
Yes. Since he can modify genes, he can change future generations.
Oh, yes, we have a power that is extraordinary, and we must use it with a great deal of care and wisdom.